MORE ON HOW GRINER WAS RELEASED
THIS MORNING ANDIDNAIATE HIS
PLANE.IS Reporte TMA THE HIGH SI
NG  OFFICIAL ROCARSTOR
BOUT, WHO IS HD AN.
IS FRORUN DIA SHOWG GRINERING R
HER PASSPORT RETURNED,SMILED, K
HOME.
>> READY FOR>>ULATIONS
>> U.S.
GRINER'S WIFE CHERELLE W VITED .
'M JUSDIOVERME EMOTI
STMOTION
THAT I HAVE RIGHW T
NCERR PRESIDENHIS
MI
>> RepELEASE THE
CULMINATION OF MANY MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH RUSSIA.
>> THIS WORK IS NOT EASY.
E GOTIATT.ANGUANIT'S MY B AS
THE CALLS ATECT
WORLD.
>>ter: THENBO
S CANNABIS OIL
RINTHS IN RUSSDETENTIOW SHE'A
BRUTALE IN A
TRFOR NOTORIOUS RUIAHAT THE
WEAPONS SMUGGLER WAS
HET 48OU MOVED
TO MOSCOW BEFORE BEING FLOWN T
ABU HEXCLACE ON TH OA ATE AIR F.
>> Reporte. WANTEDTRADE BOUTOR .
BU
ACLUSIVFR
COLONYHELAN TOLD
HE'S SURPRISED HE 'TINCLUDED.
>> I'M GREATLY DISAPPOINTED THAT
HAS NOT BEEN O  RM HARITTNEY IS
THAT TREVOR WENT
HOME WHEID, BU
DELL SITTINGRE.
MYARE CKED.
I'M READY TO GO HOME.HELAN TOLD
HIGHER LEVELHAGRINER.
HIT CEF N CHARD SPIONAENCEYE
G HOME
CHR NONE
I WHOLEHEARTEDLYIS WE
L HOME
TODAY ON TE ASBRITTNEY.eporter:
NOW IS HOW T WHELAN
HOMESS
WILL BWI.GE AND WHETHETH
AT HE IS EAR IN THAT CLUSIVE INU
HE SAYS Y  THE BETTER DEAL, THA
EXCHANGED FOR WHATLLCLASS FEN.DE
THAT THEY WILPAUL OVE
HER WAY BAHING BIG IN ANAS FOR E
STATES.
SHE ISUE
TEXAS.
WE DON'T QUITE KNO.
TH OF COURSE IS WHERE TREVOR
REID WO WHE WAS
E RUSSIANS
APRIL, AND THAT IS WHERE GRINE .
MUCHRINER'S BASKETBALL  G FOR WG
E  T BEE
LLING FO
RELEASE.
TODAY THE TEAM TED
DAYS.
OM
E S NATIONAL BASKETBALASSOCIATI.
S MORNING WHEN
YOD ?
>> THANK YOU, JAKE.
-- GO TO BED BRITTNEY'S COMING
SO I WAS ANXIOUSLYIP MORNING.
I OING TO BE
HAPPY,APPY, HAPP
BUG THT
RELEASEDHEF N.
I SO LIKE I HAN'  Q LONG TIAS AS
PURE JOY.
>> HAVRMW
IS
>> I HAVE VE NOT.U KNOW, I'VEON
R EAGUESY EVERIMAG. I ANN TO I .
SHE HAS STRIKING.
SEEING THSMILE,
EIS SOME GOOD S THERE MADE M THF
>> HAVE YOU SPOKBRITTNFAMILY AT
THENG Repor MAOURSE.THOSE ARE E
THOSE E MY BOSSES.
S, A LOT O YESRE FILLE
OF CONVERSATIONS
TEXTIN, LOTS
OF EMOJI-FILLED
I HAVE SENSS
KNOWING TH SL RESPOND TO WHEN N
NO EXPECTA THERE.
BUT I' AEN
EDO HER , LINDSAY
GAER  HERE IN THE U.S
AND THE WN ANDTHIS ET
MAGNIFICENTLY.
SO WE HAVE BEEOU KNOW, I JUST TT
TO HR THATFEN
U.S.U EXPEHA
ABLELAYING ETBALL
T'- MY FAMILY HA
ES.T'S WONDERFUL.ATO
>>.T THAT SHE'LL BE
PLIN
WAS  TN, YEAH.
>>OUW WHAT?
I EXPECT AND B.G. DOESS HER JOY.
WOULD I LOVE TO E HER BACK
AMT E TRULTE?
ABSOLUTELY.ANT B.G.
B.G., AND ONLY SHE
CAN DEINE .
BU